okay
all right hi everyone thanks a lot for
coming i'm alone
hi everyone thanks a lot for coming i'm
alan krita
i just graduated from ucst electrical
engineering and now i'm a research
fellow here in the data treatment
decision processes program and today i'd
like to tell you about a recent problem
that i worked on
and towards the end also tell you a bit
more about other problems that i'm
interested in
so let's start off with the problem
setting and to motivate this uh think
about investing in a stock market where
there are m stocks and each day at the
beginning of the day you need to choose
a distribution over the m stocks that
denotes how you are going to
split your wealth to invest into each
stock so you could say i'm going to
allocate 1 over m fraction of my wealth
uniformly into each stock or you could
say
i'm going to do 50 of my wealth on stock
one and uniformly the rest over the
other something like that right
and at the end of the day what you end
up getting is this vector of price
relatives
where each component of this vector
basically represents the value of each
stock at the end of the day to that at
the beginning of the day so
if for example xt 1 equals 2 that means
that on day t the value of stock 1
went up by a factor of two and if you
had one dollar invested in it it's now
worth two dollars
and on the other hand if it
if xt one is half then that means like
the value went down by half right and i
want to say that this general setting
encapsulates the special case of betting
on
sports match or as the original example
went uh betting on a horse race where
each day there's going to be just one
winner and the only money you get back
is what you invested in that particular
horse
this is a very important special case
we'll come back to it later
and we can see that the ratio of your
wealth
at the beginning at the end of each day
to that at the beginning of each day is
a transpose xt because this is just the
fraction you had invested in each stock
times how much that stock value rows are
depreciated just add it up over all
stocks so this is the ratio of your
wealth for one particular day
and what you want to do is invest
sequentially over n days
uh which entails constructing this
portfolio selection strategy which is
basically a collection of function that
on day number t takes uh the price
relative vectors of days one through t
minus one and tells you
how uh you should what fraction of your
wealth should you invest in each stock
so on each day you get a probability
distribution over one through m
and if you sequentially invest over n
days the ratio of your wealth finally to
on day number one is just the product of
your ratios each day and then it turns
out to be this value
and what you're hoping for is that this
sn
is large
right so perhaps the simplest example of
a portfolio selection strategy is the
so-called constant rebalance portfolio
or crp which assigns equal fraction
uh sorry which assigns the same fraction
of your wealth to a particular stock
each day so this is completely time
invariant right so this is one of the
simplest examples of the portfolio
strategy you could have
right so now let me go on and exactly
formulate the problem so this was the
definition of crps and we can argue
separately that crps are a very
reasonable benchmark class to compare
yourself against so a reasonable goal
that we can set for ourself
is to have is to create a portfolio
strategy that
achieves wealth that's comparable to the
wealth of the best constant rebalance
portfolio in hindsight even for the
worst possible case of markets to market
vectors right so so this is the
portfolio regret for a strategy a and
what you want is that this regret should
be small
and we can write this in another form by
writing down what s n is that might be
more familiar this log of product just
becomes sum and what you end up getting
is this equivalent form which looks more
like an online learning problem against
the best fixed action in hindsight for
the worst possible case of inputs and
the loss function here is the special
kind of loss sometimes called the log
loss and so this is just online learning
with this loss
okay so that was the problem formulation
let me now tell you about tom cover's
solution to this problem called
universal portfolios and really the crux
of this idea is to understand is to use
the relationship between gambling and
data compression more precisely we use
uh the fact like the fact is that
sequential portfolio selection is
equivalent to universal compression
let's look at this equivalence a bit
more closely
so how do you go from a universal
compressor to a universal portfolio
selection method it's by something
called probability induced portfolios
and how you go from portfolio selection
method to a universal compressor is by
inputting these extremely kelly price
relatives which are basically it's a
price relative that's one at just one
component and zero everywhere else so if
you remember slide one this is the case
when you're betting on a sports
tournament and each day just one team is
going to win so portfolio selection with
these input vectors turns into universal
compression and cover shows us that in
some sense the most difficult market
that you can deal with the worst
sequence of price relatives you can deal
with is when everything is uh
in the form of a kelly vector so
gambling on a horse race is the most
difficult stock market to deal with
even more precisely the equivalence is
that portfolio selection against the
best crp
is exactly the same as a universal
compression of an emory sequence against
the best
fixed iid probability right
and
so covert strategy that
makes a probability induced portfolio
out of the universal compressor is able
to achieve half log n times m minus 1
regret which is optimal including the
constant this is unsurprisingly also the
optimal redundancy that you can achieve
when you're trying to compress an mre
sequence against the best id probability
right so this was towards universal
portfolios so now i'm going to
complicate this problem a little bit and
tell you about what we studied which is
the case when at time t in addition to
the yesterday's price relatives you have
some
extra side information zt that you can
incorporate so this could be anything
a canonical example that is usually
given is the truncated history of the
market but it could even be something
additional like in cover and or dental
original
example it was how oil prices might
affect the stock market if you're
betting on a cricket match it could be
the condition of the pitch on a
particular day
anything
so we also assume that there exists a
state function g that maps the site
information to one of s states right and
this state function is not known to the
investor so you don't know how the site
information is going to map to a state
and this is what makes this work
different from coburn or dental x
portfolio selection with site
information because they consider the
case when the state is directly visible
to everyone so there's no function g in
that case
okay so in this case we can also
strengthen the benchmark and uh
allow it both the flexibility to choose
us choose and know the state function g
and also to play a statewide crp so
earlier the uh
the benchmark was restricted to using
the same uh vector at each uh the same
crp at each time step but now the crp is
allowed to adapt to the state in this
manner
and we can have this this other this
regret formulation in this case which is
very similar except that over here
we have uh best statewide crp and here
is your portfolio incorporating the site
information
right
and perhaps a very simple example of a
strategy that um
a benchmark strategy that can adapt to
site information is when you just look
at yesterday's price relatives and
decide the state according to that so
for example you could say that if
yesterday's price relative for stock one
was 1.5 then today i'm going to invest
80 percent of my wealth in stock one
otherwise i'm going to just do uniformly
at random everything so this is one
example of how you could incorporate
state into this problem
so let me just state our main result in
words so
if the following conditions are met so
firstly if the site information process
is what i've written here as stationary
plus
because it's almost the same as
stationarity a little more stringent but
quite close
so if this first condition and the
second condition that the class of state
functions has finite nitrogen dimension
which if you haven't heard of it's just
a generalization of the vc dimension to
function classes that are supported on
more than two outputs because in our
case we might possibly have more than
two states so if these two conditions
are met then we're able to construct a
portfolio selection strategy that
achieves sublinear expected wealth ratio
um
and the exact non-asymptotics depend on
the nature and properties of this
process said and
right so that was one problem that i've
worked on so before winding up let me
just tell you
real quickly about other topics that
i've worked on previously so i worked on
various topics in information theory
including universal compression
sequential uh prediction portfolio
selection and so on
information measures which is about
understanding fundamental properties of
entropy and mutual information polar
codes and so on and i'm super excited to
be here and learn from everyone about
more topics in sequential decision
making
so very related to this presentation one
topic that i'm very interested in is
understanding online learning based
methods for sequential prediction and
exactly how they differ
from compression based methods in
sequential prediction
and i'm very interested in understanding
how we can incorporate important
considerations and constraints like
fairness and privacy in sequential
prediction
and more generally i'm very interested
in understanding exactly how
information theoretic methods can help
us achieve more understanding of
data driven decision processes
so yeah
that's my presentation thanks a lot and
happy to take questions
yeah thanks for the very clear talk um
any questions
[Music]
so
uh so you mentioned this analog between
uh the gambling between gambling and
compression which was super cool had
never seen this before
is there an analog to compression when
in the presence of states
um you mentioned the history so maybe
that's perfect yeah that's what uh we
take the same approach of reducing it to
a problem of data compression with site
information
so yeah okay cool thanks
thanks for the great talk i really
enjoyed it um could you give us some
like real world examples of side
information uh like the z variable you
described yes so you could have
something like so real by real world
example you mean like real real word
mathematically so you could actually
you could have something like this you
could look at um
so for example let me give you an
example in which this these conditions
are satisfied so let's say the market
vectors are
k markov
and
the state is the state maps from the
past k vectors the past k market vectors
to something in that case these
conditions are satisfied and you can uh
you know have a you know compete with
the benchmark that knows the state so
that's one example
you know you could look at something
like this you could look at looking at
whether yesterday's price relatives lie
in a certain rectangle or not and that's
also
acceptable class and in real life
i like covers example was like oil
prices i i don't know much about that
but
if you're gambling on cricket you can
you know
know whether any players have any
injuries or something like that yeah
thank you very much yeah
okay
thanks again for the questions offline
uh
thanks again next speaker can set up